[Music]
so
[Music]
coming up on your weekly news show a
kite festival to remind us about the
plight of refugees from afghanistan the
people used to fly them a lot before
they got banned by the taliban
and clearing up our oceans a teenager on
a mission to get rid of marine litter
the oceans around us in the uk are
really important and if you go diving
down there it's amazing
[Music]
hello if you want to know what's going
on in the world right now you've come to
the right place yep and this week we're
looking at the fallout from two
different conflicts starting with the
war in ukraine yeah it's been six months
since russia invaded ukraine and the
fighting goes on millions of families
have had to flee their country and you
may have even had some ukrainian kids
joining your school but why is russia
doing this and what's it all about if
you don't get it don't worry because
i've been trying to find out
to truly understand why ukraine has been
invaded by russia we need to hit the
history books and go back inside
[Music]
from 1917 when the royal russian family
were overthrown
until 1991
we saw the rise and the fall of the
soviet union or the ussr ukraine was one
of the 15 states that made up this giant
country
all of them became independent countries
when the soviet union's political system
and economy collapsed in 1991 and its
people demanded change russia was the
country with the biggest power
surrounded by smaller states as you can
see here
russia's current president vladimir
putin came to power in 2000 he has
always made it clear that the end of the
soviet union angers him and some world
leaders believe he would like russia to
become a huge empire similar to how the
soviet union used to be back in the day
and he wants to claim back some of the
former soviet states
in 2008 russia invaded neighbouring
georgia and took control of a large part
of the country
it's very much like what he's doing with
ukraine now
trying to take back a former state that
largely wants to be independent of
russian control
2014 is a good year to look at the
relationship between ukraine and russia
the then president of ukraine with a
close relationship to russia faced huge
protests demanding he quit and when he
did russia's vladimir putin thought that
ukraine was about to become more
friendly with western countries like the
uk
and the usa
so he sent in russian soldiers to take
control of crimea which is an area in
the south of ukraine
let's travel in time right up to the
present day the ukraine invasion is now
a very complicated situation
rebels are people who go against the
government in power
in february russia sent in its troops to
support rebels from the regions of
luhansk and donetsk the rebels wanted to
be independent from ukraine
so rebels with russians began fighting
against the ukrainian army
but the most important thing to know is
that this was just the start of a
full-scale invasion of ukraine
president putin appeared on russian tv
to want other countries not to try and
stop them
there is huge support for ukraine here
in the west for all his bombs and tanks
and missiles i don't believe that the
russian dictator will ever subdue the
national feeling of the ukrainians and
their passionate belief that their
country should be free
there are still large russian
communities in many former soviet states
including ukraine while some would like
to be part of russia world leaders say
president putin has no right to wade in
six months on from the start of the
invasion many cities lie in ruins
and the russians have taken control of
large areas in the south and the east of
the country
but ukrainian forces are refusing to
give in and with help of weapons supply
from western countries including the uk
president zelinski remains determined to
defend his country
[Music]
for ukrainian children living in the uk
hearing about the war can be very
upsetting for them as they still have
friends and family back home so we're
being joined by dr chris kandaya he's
part of a charity called the sanctuary
foundation they've been helping loads of
ukrainian people fleeing the war to find
host families here in the uk so am i
right in saying that you've got someone
staying with you that's right we've got
a lovely lady called natasha she feels
already part of our family even though
we've only known her a month she's a
fantastic cook and so we've tried this
new food to us called borscht which is
actually a cabbage soup which doesn't
sound very appetizing but it's really
good so for many ukrainian children who
have joined our school they still have
friends and family back home how should
we be helping them through this
difficult time that's such a good
question maya lots of the kids that are
here are just with their mums and
they're worried about their uncles and
their fathers and their grandparents i
think for kids arriving at a school
often you don't want to stick out so you
don't want to be known as the refugee or
the ukrainian just just another kid and
so i think just being sensitive asking
people if they're okay you know
including them in things making sure
that they feel part of the gang rather
than outside i think everybody can do
that as well they're not you know
everybody can welcome someone in a
friend group exactly i think sometimes
little things like trying to learn a
little bit of the ukrainian language
might be a nice way that you're showing
value to another person they're so happy
when you just say a little thing like uh
yaks bravo means how are you yes bravo
yeah oh mate you're a natural right
someone asked you that you say
does your daughter which means
great so just little things like this
just help people know that we're there
for them we're listening and we're doing
what we can to make them feel welcome a
lot of families are facing uncertainty
about where they'll live once their
agreement with the uk families come to
an end and that's a lot of pressure for
them really isn't it it is it would be
great if we could help people stay where
they are and we've got a little campaign
that we're running at sanctuary
foundation getting both our ukrainian
friends and those that are hosting them
to write a letter to the government so
you could encourage people to make use
of that and i think something not a lot
of people like think about is you know
what about the russian children can't
even imagine what would be going through
their head when they see what their own
army is doing yeah it's so difficult i
think for a lot of russians in russia
and russians that are here they're not
supporting what's going on that's not
their army that's their government's
army and they're not behind it so i
think that's another thing that we can
do try to bring peace and reconciliation
in our schools and not allow prejudice
and stereotypes to rule thank you so
much for talking to us oh it's my
pleasure
now there's nothing we love more at fyi
than trying to spot fake news so let's
see if you can figure out which one of
these stories is dodgy
[Music]
the world's richest man elon musk has
told millions of people on social media
that he's buying manchester united but
could that really be true
or how about this story apparently sean
the sheep is going on nasa's latest moon
mission does that sound like fake news
or is it one giant leap for lamkin
[Music]
still to come on this week's programme
underwater litter picking to try and
save our planet
[Music]
it's been just over a year since british
and american forces pulled out of
afghanistan leaving a militant group
called the taliban to take control
many afghan people were worried about
this because the taliban have very
strict rules about the way people can
live their lives yeah the history of
this is quite complicated isn't it back
in 2001 america and its allies including
the uk
invaded afghanistan because the taliban
was supporting terrorist groups
but as soon as british and american
troops left the country last year the
taliban came straight back into power
they follow an extreme version of islam
and they don't allow girls to get an
education with the taliban back in
control afghan people who'd worked with
the british military were in great
danger so the uk agreed to take in more
than 20 000 refugees
but a year on many of them are still
living in temporary hotels yeah so to
mark the one year anniversary some
people who fled to the uk have been
flying kites and i went along to find
out why
have been one of the oldest traditions
of afghanistan it's 800 years old if not
more
the people used to fly them a lot before
they got banned by the taliban
it's more than a pastime it's an art
form it's something that brings
everybody together
arrows is 15 years old and was born in
the uk but still has fun memories of
flying kites with his family who are
back home in afghanistan they've been
living under the taliban rule for just
over a year now kites whenever we lift
our kites high into the sky it just
reminds me of a thunderstorm we used to
go there every day with our cousins and
family and friends we used to have a
fight with kites
this kite flying festival is a chance
for everyone here to celebrate their
culture and to remind people of the
plight of afghan refugees
there was a time when the taliban banned
kite flying as well as many other
expressions of joy like music and
dancing so keeping the tradition alive
is hugely important for african refugees
who are trying to make a new home in the
uk so i'm here with jay and jaden can
you show me how to fly the kites sure
you just tuck it up and then i've seen
people holding it and then
voila
in afghanistan they tried obviously
evacuating from there but it was
unpossible because the taliban had
flocked everywhere they blocked the
airports the borders to each country i
just want them to just carry on with
what's going on until we're finished and
get sorted out
[Music]
i've met so many different people and
i've learned so much about the afghani
culture but what's really opened my eyes
is that no matter where some of these
people are in the world they still make
time for their culture even if it's
something as simple as coming out on a
warm windy day to come fly a kite and
it's really lovely how many people came
to support them
it's so important to hold on to to the
roots and to what makes afghanistan
my country my land it's the music it's
the food it's the kites in the sky it's
the pigeons over kabul
[Music]
check out this summer holiday video
that's gone viral on social media these
guys are on a beach on the greek island
of scathos but it also happens to be
right next to the airport runway hold on
to your sun hats
[Music]
now this is quite shocking
water companies have been pumping
untreated sewage water into the sea at
over 50 beaches in the uk
it's because some drains and sewers
couldn't handle the amount of heavy rain
some parts of the uk have had just
recently yeah things got so bad that
swimmers were told it wasn't safe to go
in the water but it's not just sewage
you need to look out for the equivalent
of a truckload of plastic waste is
dumped into our oceans every single
minute it's bad for marine life but it
also contributes to climate change
oliver who lives near bristol wanted to
show us how he's doing his bit to try
and make a difference
[Music]
today we're in wales we're in
pembrokeshire we're going to dive with
neptune's army of rubbish cleaners just
on a boat out there we're going to pick
up loads of marine litter
the oceans around us in the uk are
really important because they
host so many types of fish and mammals
and different creatures and so many
different habitats they're very
biodiverse and if you go diving down
there it's amazing
i got in the water i quickly spotted a
lobster pot
a lobster what's the kind of trap that
fishing crews use for catching things
like lobsters
and in this one i can also see a female
spider crab and a few velvet swimming
crabs
by bringing the lobster pot back onto
the boat we can save the lives of these
creatures and reduce marine litter
well done ollie
so i'm going to release this lobster
back into the sea
yeah he's a he's a big one
there you go
when a fisherman has lost their fishing
line or lobster pots due to a storm or
some sharp rocks or something they will
continue to pick up fish lobsters crabs
at least 10 percent of marine litter is
estimated to be made up of fishing waste
abandoned fishing gear is responsible
for harming 66
of marine mammal species it felt really
special when we were going down picking
up these pots taking them out because
there were so many animals inside each
pot and to think that those could have
kept on fishing and all the animals
inside those pots would have just died
and we got them out in the end
and if there's something you'd like to
report on for fyi then the best way is
to join the fyin news club we love it
when you get in touch with us so check
out the details on our website
first.news fyi and you could be on
screen before you know it
check out this incredible photograph
that's just been released showing the
planet jupiter it was taken from the
world's most powerful telescope and you
can even see a giant storm moving across
the planet now that is out of this world
[Music]
now speaking of space how did you get on
with this week's fake news or fact
the story about sean the sheep blasting
off on a moon mission with nasa is a
fact the aardman character is
representing the european space agency
on an uncrewed flight eventually nasa
wants to take the first female astronaut
to the moon
now as for the story about the world's
richest man elon musk buying manchester
united
well he did write that on social media
and lots of people believed him but it
turns out he was only joking so that was
the fake story
[Music]
well that's it for today but we're going
to leave you with some brilliant shots
of animals enjoying a drink during the
hot weather yes sue cross is a farmer in
suffolk but she also loves to take
videos of the animals that pop up on her
farm and just recently they've been
loving the trays of water that she
leaves out for them great work sue and
we'll see you next week bye
[Music]
you